la conférence que je vais avoir
l'honneur de faire devant vous sous la
présidence honorifique effectué de
monsieur anatole béchard le grand
spécialiste de la sinusite et des
refroidissements et de refuge et le gras
le premier al filistini le premier à
voter sur le puy-de-dôme aura trait
aujourd'hui à mon délire exploit comment
j'ai planté le drapeau français au
sommet du mont mama les repas 12 mille
mètres d'altitude
je ne m'étendrai pas davantage sur
moi-même beaucoup d'autres l'ont déjà
fait je rappellerai brièvement les
tripes des conférences données à l'issue
de mes nombreux voyages week end chez
les pygmées la bourboule et son folklore
vingt mille lieues sous les mers excepté
un excellent mix une confession aux
passants j'étais un peu las vous voyagez
je décide et non de consacrer nous
attend à la rédaction de mon livre de
souvenirs qui doit paraître à
incessamment chez arthème fayard et
l'entretien de mots [ __ ] suspens
eh bien voyez-vous je vends bourgeoise
un beau matin d'octobre en pleine
giboulées jouant au rhume le professeur
méchas appelé en consultation le conseil
l'aptitude ma décision fut prise en un à
l'instant jacques après le mouvement
n'est pas douze mille et une anecdotes
aux façons c'était en inde
non tu d'une bourse délivrés par les
échanges culturels et du musée de la
femme je décision de partir dans les
plus mauvaises solutions possibles mais
gare mes bagages sont vite fait un bond
trick où on enrôle ont un pot de saintdo
pour enduire m'est cher et le plus
important le drapeau français sexe en
faire par les anciens de la pétanque de
roubaix dont vous connaissez tous la
devise
prends ta boule dans la bave au bout
pour les réponses je décidé de faire de
l'auto stop jusqu'à marseille
je me pose des dons au bord de la route
et attendit avait qui motorisait pour me
rapprocher du tibet au bout de trois
heures un motocycliste me prit en troupe
rega nous on est dans sa famille à dix
kilomètres de là et qui m'a fait une
branche pour y passer la nuit
la grande aventure commence
je passais sur les différentes
péripéties mont royal
nos journées à béziers
ça l'intérêt mon badge movie reliant aux
situations banales et c'était toujours
les partenaires on arrive directement
dans la petite ville de feu ou bon
dernier rate avant l'ascension deux
choses importantes ont occupé mon sp la
première acheter des provisions de
bouche partage et la deuxième trouver
des indigènes pour m'indiquer le
meilleur chemin
deux jeunes un dégel s'étend à ma vue
frappé le font avec l'index grand signe
d'acceptation coutume je pense en
confiance je décide de partir sur le
champ à la première attaque mais deux
chercheurs pas s'enfuir en emportant
tout bête mais vaine
je me trouvais dans seul et nu au pied
des neiges éternelles
mais fidèle à ma devise va jusqu'au bout
je veux drapé dans quel que soit l'âge
est parti vers ce sommet magique qui
émergeaient des modèles une anecdote en
passant juge tient souligné
il faisait perdre en caverne d'avalanche
en avallon je me rapproche lentement du
sommeil à 8500 mètres d'altitude super
une babouche
en club en paix dans une bonne veine
poupe et gens continuent toujours
joyeuse une avec toi t'as pas cent
j'étais furieuse clémente envers leur
faveur une avalanche à montjean soudain
vous allez voir c'est impressionnant
quand on est seul avec la nature soudain
au détour d'un pic comme comme vous
diriez comme ça il ya le but et on
prenait pour un film
il me semble entendre une voix étrange
je pense que ma raison ces gars mossos
glace de meuvaines serait ce par hasard
l'abominable homme des neiges
mais est ce qu'on lit dans les journaux
ce qui rend pas ne l'ont jamais vu
jamais touché je m'approche et sam est
touché ça fait il m'a simplement derrien
rhume par un pot imposition des pâtes
des grosses pannes une chapelle et des
mains quoi je sais pas quoi faire de mon
drapeau je lui ai donné si vous savez ce
qu'il en a fait les frais
noémie j'étais maintenant il est abonné
biarritz